[موسيقى]
مع بدايه الانتفاضه الفلسطينيه الثانيه
صحى ضمير بعض الضباط من الطيارين
الاسرائيليين وضباط المخابرات لما راوه من
ممارسات وصفوها بالارهاب ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني سلع بعضهم لاحقا الى توقيع
عريضه ضمت اكثر من 43 ضابطا وطيار ومن
جهاز الاستخبار
عنوانها لن اخدم في جيش الاحتلال تمرد بدا
انه على المجتمع العسكري الاسرائيلي اكثر
من كونه تمردا على الجيش الاسرائيلي ذاته
فال الاسرائيلي يتربى منذ صغره على الحياه
في مجتمع عسكري قصه التمرد هذه ظروف
نشاتها وحجمها وافاقها وتاثيرها على الجيش
الاسرائيلي واحتلاله للاراضي الفلسطينيه
سنشاهد القصه رافضون و ناقشها مع ضيفين من
تل ابيب الكاتب والصحفي جدع ليفي والعقيد
المتقاعد المختص في الشان الفلسطيني
والشرق الاوسط الدكتور رؤوفين بيركو نيشير
الى اننا وجهنا دعوه الى المتحدث باسم
الجيش الاسرائيلي افيخاي ادرعي للمشاركه
معنا في الحلقه لكنه اعتذر لحجه عدم حصوله
على ترخيص من مؤسسته العسكريه ننوه
مشاهدين الى اننا شرعنا منذ ثلاثه ايام في
تلقي مساهماتكم عبر مختلف منصات التواصل
الاج
سنعرض ما اريد منها خلال النقاش في حلقتنا
هذه امامكم الان على الشاشه ارقام
للمشاركه المرئيه اضافه الى الوسم الخاص
بالحلقه والظاهر على الشاشه رايكم الان
مشاهدينا الكرام ان نتابع قصه
[موسيقى]
رافضون
خاض ال التمار عصفا ذهنيا قبل ان تحسم
موقفها فيما تعده اهم قرار في حياته
هي اليوم على بعد اسابيع من الدخول الى
السجن العسكري الذي اثارته على ان تكون
مجنده في جيش
الاحتلال وان تحمل السلاح في وجه
الفلسطينيين مع ان قرار الدخول الى السجن
ليس سهلا لكنني حسمت امري وانا انتظر
اللحظه التي ساصل فيها الى مكتب التجنيد
واعلن رفضي للتجنيد ي ان اكون جزءا من
منظومه الاحتلال فكل وظيفه او مهمه في
الجيش مسخره للاحتلال وانا لا ارغب بان
اكون جزءا من منظومه تقمع شعبا
[موسيقى]
اخر في مرحله مبكره من عمرها ادركت ر حجم
ما يقترفه الجيش الاسرائيلي من فضائع
وجرائم وايقنت كذلك انها لن تكون مجنده في
جيش يقتل ويقمع ويتحكم بكل تفاصيل حياه
الفلسطينيين فسجن سته
اشهر الاحتلال هو سيطره شعب على شعب اخر
وطالما ان هنالك حكما عسكريا لا يعقل ان
تحدث جرائم في ظل واقع
كهذا اترت ان اقول الحقيقه وان اتحدث عن
امور لا يرغب الجيش بسماعها فهو اصلا لا
يعترف بانه جيش محتل ويحاول دائما ان يكنس
هذه الحقيقه تحت البساط يريدنا ان نخرس
وانا قلت انني لن اخرس بعد
اليوم لا يحظى كثيرون من [__] الخدمه
العسكريه بدعم عائلاتهم على عكس تمار التي
كان عصيان والدها حين للاوامر
العسكريه حافزا لها للسير على
خطاه انا فخور جدا بها لان لديها كل هذه
القوه والجراه لان تتحدى كل الاصوات التي
تحاول ثنيها عنما تؤمن به وعن قرارها في
رفض الخدمه العسكريه انا جدا مسرور من
اجلها
قراري تاثر بالتربيه التي تلقيتها في
البيت وما من شك ان كون والدي عصى الاوامر
العسكريه كان له تاثير في ذلك وان لم يكن
السبب الوحيد فقد تربيت على ان انتقد
الاشياء وان اضع الحدود وان ارى ما
يناسبني ايه
كانت الاراضي الفلسطينيه تشهد اوج
الانتفاضه الثانيه عندما بدات في صفوف
الجيش الاسرائيلي حركه عصيان للاوامر
العسكريه قاد التحرك طيارون في سلاح الجو
وضباط وجنود احتياط من وحدات النخبه
كسياره متكال التابعه لهيئه الاركان ولواء
المدرعات
الجيش الاسرائيلي منظمه ارهابيه لا اريد
ان اكون جزءا منها فهي مسؤوله عن قتل الاف
الاطفال وعن الاستيطان على اراضي
الفلسطينيين وعن غارات مجنونه على احياء
امنه في غزه هذه منظمه
تح
لا احاول ان اجمل
الامور لقد هدمت منازل وجرحت واعتقلت
اشخاصا جرحت روح اخرين وجرحت روحي ايضا من
كل هذا العنف لكن من حسن حظي انني لم اقتل
احدا طيله خدمتي العسكريه لكن الجرح
موجود
بدات ادرك ان
دولتي وجيش بلادي ينفذون سياسه
منهجيه تتمثل بالقمع والتنكيل والسطو
بالقوه ولانني كنت جزء من ذلك شعرت
بالخزي
[موسيقى]
لكن عصيان الاوامر العسكريه لم يقف عند
الوحدات القتاليه بل امتد عقب العدوان على
غزه عام
2014 الى وحده استخبارات سريه ذا ع صيتها
وتعرف باسم
8 كنا 43 ضابطا وجن في الاحتياط وقعنا على
الرساله وقلنا اننا نرفض ان نقوم باي عمل
ضد الشعب الفلسطيني واننا نرفض ان نكون
جزء من الاحتلال الاستخبارات عمل قذر فانت
تبتز الناس لتحصل على المعلومات وجل ذلك
ليس للحفاظ على الامن بل لتعزيز السيطره
على الشعب
الفلسطيني شباب الله اكبر شباب
[موسيقى]
الله لم يكن عصيان الاوامر العسكريه خلال
الانتفاضه الثانيه وبعدها وليد اللحظه بل
هو حصيله تراكميه من احداث داميه اوقعت
الاف المدنيين الفلسطينيين الابرياء بين
قتيل
وجريح
لا سما في عمليات اغتيال كانت تستهدف
انذاك قاضه الصف الاول في المقاومه
الفلسطين الغاره التي هزتني وهزت اخرين من
الطيارين ممن اعلنوا عصيان الاوامر كانت
الغاره التي اغتيل فيها صلاح شحاده في
غزه لقد قتل 15 مدنيا وجرح 150 على الاقل
قنبله تزن طنا القيت على احد الاماكن
الاكثر اكتظاظا في العالم في اللحظه التي
سقطت فيها القنبله انهار شيء ما في
داخلي عندما ترى صفوف القتلى شه الاطفال
والرضع في الاخبار وفي الجرائد وفي
المقابل تسمع تبريرات القاده والحكومه بان
لا مناص من ذلك وانه لا ضير في ذلك فانك
تدرك انهم يكذبون
عليك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ر
لقد كنت مسؤولا عن نقل جنود الكوماندو
والجنود الذين جلسوا في بطن الطائره لم
يكن هدفهم زرع الورود في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه لذلك اشعر انني اتحمل
المسؤوليه عنما فعله هؤلاء الجنود حتى لو
انني لا اعلم ما الذي فعلوه نحن الطيارين
الذين وقعنا على رساله اعلان عصيان
الاوامر العسكريه هجمنا قالوا ان معظمنا
لم ينفذ غارات جويه لكنني اقول انني لست
ملزما ان اكون قاتلا بنفسي لكي ادرك ان
القتل ممنوع لكنني نقلت
قتله كنت في جنوب الخليل كان الجيش حينها
يقوم باجلاء الفلسطينيين من منازلهم في
بلده سوسيا
والتونا وام الخير بدات ادرك كيف يبدو
الامر من الطرف الاخر وان ثمه منظومه
ممنهجه
وظيفتها ان تبقي الفلسطينيين في الحضيض
وان لا يرفعوا
رؤوسهم في المقابل تستولي هذه المنظومه
على اراضي
الفلسطينيين
بالقوه وتمنحها
للمستوطنين ادركت حينها ان دولتي
وجيشها تطبق سياسه
ممنهجه من السطو وقمع
الفلسطينيين
[موسيقى]
الاستخبارات كما في كل حكم عسكري تلعب
دورا مصيريا في تحطيم المجتمع من الخل صل
على المعلومات لكي تمنع اي ثوره او تغيير
الواقع كل شخص هو هدف بعينه كل شخص هو مهم
وبامكانه ان يزودنا بمعلومات مهمه اذا كان
شخص ما مريضا بامكاننا ان نعرض عليه
العلاج او اذا كان شخص يتلقى العلاج في
اسرائيل فبالامكان تهديده بقطع العلاج ان
لم يتعاون معنا اذا كان شخص لديه شذوذ
جنسي غير مقبول في المجتمع ولا يريد ان
ينفضح امره فبالامكان تهديده بذلك احيانا
نضع هذا الشخص في حاله خطر على حياته
عمليا نحن نهده بالموت ويصبح امام طريق
بدون مخرج اما ان نفضح امره ويضطر الى
الهرب او ان يتعاون معنا ضد شعبه او
اصدقائه او حتى افراد
اسرته وصلت رسائل عصيان الاوامر الى قياده
الجيش والى ديوان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائ
انذاك اري شارون الذي كان يقمع انتفاضه
الفلسطينيين بالحديد
والنار فاهتزت اسرائيل لحدث كان شاذا في
المؤسسه
العسكريه رفضي للخدمه في الاراضي المحتله
كان اولا بمثابه توجه للمجتمع الاسرائيلي
لانهاء الاحتلال اردنا ان نقول ان
الاحتلال يدمرنا كمجتمع من الداخل البعد
الاخر هو ما قمنا به كجنود انعدام العداله
التي كنا جز منها والجرائم التي
ارتكبناها كنا 13 ضابطا وجنديا واعلن انه
في حال تلقينا اوامر للخدمه في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه فلن نفعل نعم بالامكان رؤيه
ذلك عصيانا للاوامر
العسكريه كل واحد بامكانه ان يتحول الى
قاتل اذا سمح لنفسه بالبقاء داخل منظومه
كهذه من جهه غسيل دماغ من جهه اخرى
تبريرات من جانب الحكومه ومن جهه الثالثه
قبليه وتخويف على وجودنا كدوله وهكذا تصبح
قاتله لقد وقع 27 طيارا في سلاح الجو على
رساله اهم ما جاء فيها ان اوامر القياده
العسكريه غير قانونيه وهي بمثابه جرائم
ونحن نرفض ان نكون مجرمين ولن نمتثل
لاوامرك
[موسيقى]
لم يرى عامه الاسرائيليين بعين الرضا هذا
التحرك وثمت من اعتبره خيانه لا
تغتفر من ينشر غسيله خارجا لتفعيل ضغط على
اسرائيل فهذا نوع من الخيانه لكن ليس من
النوع الذي يحتم اطلاق النار على الخائن
اعتقد ان لديهم مشكله في التربيه ويجب ان
يستثمروا اكثر في حبهم لارض اسرائيل ودوله
خساره انهم يحملون هذه
الاراء لا اتفق مع هذه المجموعه هم لا
يقررون من هو المحتل وما هو الاحتلال يجب
على الجميع ان يحترم قرارات الحكومه نحن
ندافع عن
انفسنا فليقولوا انني خائنه انا لا ارفض
الخدمه لانني اريد ان اقبع بالسجن او لكي
ينعتني بالخائن انني افعل ذلك لانني اريد
ان اعيش بمكان
افضل نعم لقد نتونا بالخونه
وبمجرد فاع صرح انه يجب ان نمثل للمحاكمه
كمجرمين رغم اننا لسنا كذلك ولم نخالف
القانون والدليل انهم لم يزج بنا بالسجن
واكتفوا بتسريح من
الوحده بعد ع 20 100 سنه قادتنا المجرمون
سيذكرهم التاريخ كقتله اطفال وربما اذا
شئنا مجتمعا عادلا هنا فان النموذج الذي
سيحتلون به هو نحن الذين رفضنا اليوم ان
نقتل او ان نكون شركاء في القمع وانعدام
العداله
الانسانيه كون الانتقاد صدر من وحده
النخبه في الجيش ثمه من راى في ذلك تهديدا
فوص مون ك خونه وغدارين معاونين مع
العدو اتهمونا اننا خونا واننا قمنا
بانقلاب عسكري ما قلناه وحسب هو اننا لن
نخدم بالجيش ومن يرغب فلينم الينا بعد
اشهر بداوا بالزج بالجنود الرافضين في
السجن تلقيت امر استدعاء للخدمه في غزه
وقلت لن امتثل زجوا بي في السجن لمده شهر
كانت تلك مرحله مفصليه في حياتي شعرت انني
بهذا الطريق اخدم شعبي على اكمل وجه وانني
ادفع ثمنا لموقفي بان لا اخدم في جيش
الاحتلال لم يرق لقادتنا ما فعلناه فقاموا
بتسريح من الخدمه ومنعونا من التحليق في
الجو في تلك اللحظه لم اشعر بذره ندم ولو
كنت نادما على شيء
ان
افعل لقد كان عصيان الاوامر حدثا صادما في
مجتمع يرسخ النزعه العسكريه لدى الاطفال
في جيل مبكر ويزرع لديهم الهواجس عن مخاطر
تهدد وجود
اسرائيل فينشون على الروح العدوانيه
وازدراء العمل وشطنه الفلسطينيين ونفي
وجو نحن نتربى على ان مسار حياتنا كله
مرتبط بالجيش وبان انا في خطر وجودي
محاطون بالاعداء من كل صوب بالدول العربيه
التي تريد محو اسرائيل من الوجود وانه اذا
لم نخذ بالجيش فان عالمنا سينهار وستزول
اسرائيل تعرضت لغسيل دماغ كباقي الاطفال
اذا دخلت اليوم الى مدرسه ثانويه فانك
سترى ضباطا يدخلون ويخرجون ويغسلون ادمغه
الاطفال باكاب عن
الواقع لقد كان بديهيا بالنسبه لي ان اخدم
في الجيش كجندي مقاتل وان اصبح ضابطا
وادافع عن الملجا الوحيد لليهود في
العالم يتزايد عدد الرافضين للخدمه
العسكريه في جيش الاحتلال من منطلقات
سياسيه وان ظلت الحالات هامشيه فانه لا
يمكن مع ذلك حصر حجمها باحصائيات رسميه
دقيقه يتعمد الجيش الاسرائيلي اخفائها
ويتبع طرقا ملتويه للتستر
عليها الجيش ليس معنيا فقط باخفاء الظاهره
بل هو لا يعترف في وجودها فاذا اعلن مجند
رفضه للخدمه من منطلقات سياسيه فان الجيش
يتجاهل ذلك ويعتبر الرافض اما مجنونا او
يرفض اطاعه الاوامر ويسرح من الجيش بهذه
المسوغات لكنه لا يقر البت بوجود من يرفض
الخدمه في جيش
محتل اعتقد ان الجيش يخاف من ان تنمو
الظاهره ومن ان يكثر اشخاص امثالنا ممن
يحملون افكارا ضد الاحتلال ويجرون على
البوح بذلك فانا مثلا رحت من الجيش على
بند التصرف السيء والخطير هي في الواقع
محاوله لنبد من المجتمع رغم ان ذلك مثير
للسخريه ويوج في
الحقيقه كانت ظاهره عصيان الاوامر في
فترتنا واسعه ولم يكن امام الجيش الا ان
يزج
بالرافضة لكن رويدا رويدا ايقنوا ان عليهم
عزل الرافضين كان يعرضوا على فلان يخدم في
عياده طبيه او ان يلتحق اخر بوحده في
النقب كنوع من اخماد الظاهره وعدم اعارتها
اهتماما
[موسيقى]
زائدا بعض الرافضين يزج بهم في العزل
الانفرادي وهي عقوبه يفرضها الجيش على اي
مخالفه صغير
الس وفي العزل يتعرض الرافضون الى تنكيل
شديد احد الرافضين اجبر على ان يجلس وينظر
الى زاويه معينه في الزنزانه واذا ازاح
نظره كانوا يعاقبون بان يدور في الرواق
عده مرات كانت حاله لشخص متدين رفض ان
يلبس البزه
العسكريه فاجبه على الصلاه بملابسه
الداخليه وهذا امر مهين من الناحيه
الدينيه
والعقائديه لقد حاولوا كسر عزيمتي لقد قال
لي احد الضباط من تظنين نفسك ان كل الناس
الذين جاؤوا اليوم للتضامن معك خارج السجن
سيبيت ليلتهم في فراشهم وفي منازلهم اما
انت فستذهب الى السجن ستكونين وحيده لقد
تعمد اذلالي لكي اشعر
[موسيقى]
قبل عده سنوات احد الرافضين وافق على
الخدمه بعد ان كسروا ارادته وارسلوه الىى
نابلس في مهمه
حراسه وفي اليوم الاول من خدمته اقدم على
الانتحار بطلق ناري لانه شعر انه خالف
[موسيقى]
عم لم يكتفي رافضو الخدمه العسكريه بعصيان
الاوامر فشكل بعضهم مع مقاومين فلسطينيين
القوا سلاحهم وتخلوا عن الكفاح المسلح
حركه مقاتلون من اجل الس
ونقلوا احتجاجاتهم ضد الاحتلال
وممارساته الى
الميدان عندما اعتقدت كمواطن انه علي ان
اخدم في الجيش فعلت ذلك وعندما ادركت ان
كل ما يفعله جيشنا هو احتلال الفلسطينيين
قلت انني لن اخدم في صفوفه اشعر مع
اصدقائي الفلسطينيين هنا انني افعل الامر
الصواب لكنني مازلت اسرائيليا كهؤلاء
الجنود تماما وانا امل ان يصلوا الى
قناعتي وان يخلعوا بزته العسكريه ويلقوا
بسلاحهم وينضم
الينا مسؤوليتنا كبيره لانهاء الحكم
العسكري لاننا كنا جزءا من ثقافه استخدام
السلاح والعنف وتربينا على خدمه الصراع
المسلح علينا ان لا نرضى لغيرنا ما لا
نرضاه
لانفسنا
لقد ان الاوان غدا ساتو الى مكتب التجنيد
وساعلن رفضي للخدمه العسكريه ان هذا امر
مهم جدا في حياتي وانا مسروره لانني حسمت
موقفي
هذا
خائفه اي لانني امثل اقليه بين كل هذا
العدد الكبير من المجندين وبسبب الصحافه
والناس الذين جاؤوا
لدعمي تختلط علي
المشاعر دموعي تنهمر فخرا
بتم لانها اتخذت موقفا شجاعا وستدفع الثمن
قلقه عليها كونها ستدخل
[موسيقى]
السجن انا فخور ان ما فعلته ابنتنا تاير
يستمر وبنات اخريات يعلن رفضهن للخدمه
عريه انها بدايه جيده لانهاء الحروب كوني
قويه لان اليوم الاول هو الاصعب لكن تذكري
انك تقومين بالامر
[موسيقى]
الصواب رافضون صوت تعال من داخل الكيان
متصب للارض الفلسطينيه يرفض ممارساته
ويفضحها شهد شاهد من عندهم وقصه نتعرف على
بقيتها الليله نرحب بكم مجددا مشاهدينا
الكرام نذكر باننا نواصل تلقي ارائكم
واسئلتكم بشان موضوع حلقتنا عبر حسابنا
على تويتر وصفحتنا على موقع فيسبوك مره
اخرى نرحب بضيفي من تل ابيب الكاتب
والصحفي جدعون ليفي والعقيد المتقاعد
المختص في الشان الفلسطيني والشرق الاوسطي
الدكتور روبين بيركو نبدا معك سييد جدع
ليفي ولعل اكبر خشيه لدى الجيش الاسرائيلي
ما نقوم به الليله الحديث عن هذه القصه
ونشرها اعلاميا الموضوع الذي يحاول في
واقع الامر التكتم عليه وانكاره والتقليل
من اهميته بالتالي نود ان نسال عن ظروف
نشاه هذا التمرد وهذا الرفض
لدى هؤلاء في الخدمه في جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
حسنا نحن نتحدث حول مجموعه صغيره ولكن
مجموعه شرسه
وشجاعه تقاوم هذا التوجه الموجود داخل
مؤسسه الجيش والتي تحاول ان ترفع الشرعيه
عن المؤسسه العسكريه كما قلت مجموعه شجاع
جدا وتقاوم بشرسه من الصعب ان تقوم بهذا
في هذه الاجواء وفي هذا المحيط والداخل
مجموعه او داخل هذا المجتمع الذي ينظر الى
هذه الامور بنظره مغايره هناك طبعا دعم
كبير
لوسائل الاعلام التي تحرض ضد هذه المجموعه
النتائج كما تعلمون هي نتائج محتشمه
ونتائج ضعيفه لانه من الصعب ان نتحرك على
هكذا ارضيه في هكذا
مجتمع الجيش لا يدخر جهدا للتقليل من
اهميه هذا العمل حتى لا يحلم الشباب اخرون
من المضيف في هذا الطريق سي جدعون تقول
بان الاعداد قليله لكن هذه المجموعه شجاعه
وشرسه ما الذي يجعلها كذلك ان كان العدد
قليل هل كون هؤلاء ينتمون للنخبه نتحدث عن
سلاح الطيران نتحدث عن الاستخبارات هل هذا
ما يعطي الموضوع بعدا
واهميه
لوي لو كان لدينا مؤسسات اعلاميه شجاعه لو
كان لدينا مجتمع شجاع لو كان لدينا حديث
را صريح حول الاحتلال وحول ثمن الاحتلال
ولو كان بلدنا له ثقه عاليه بالنفس فس
نتوقع الكثير من المجموعات الاخرى التي
ستقوم بعمل مشابه لانه
بنهايه المطاف نجد ان هناك غسل لدمغ الناس
خاصه الشباب ليس هناك نقاش مفتوح حول
مجموعه من المواضع وليست هناك خطوات شجاعه
من قبل
المجتمع الداخلي اذا من يحتج ومن يحاول
الاشاره بالصبه الى مواطن الخطا يتم سحب
البساط من تحت اقدامهم ويحرموا من التاثير
على الراي العام بسبب ممارسات مؤسسه الجيش
والحكومه والمؤسسه الاعلاميه والاله
الاعلاميه التي تقطع عليهم الطريق ل تاثير
على اي شريحه من المشريع هناك تعتيم
اعلامي كبير اسرائيليا على الاقل على هذا
الموضوع الذي نطرحه للنقاش الليله دعني
اتحول للسيد روبين سمعت ما ذكره السيد
جدعون اذا هناك غسل الادمغه لهذه الاجيال
من الاسرائيليين محاوله عسكره المجتمع
الاسرائيلي تخويفه من هذا المحيط داخليا
من الفلسطينيين الذين يحتلون ارضهم ولكن
من المحيط العربي المحيط بهم ايضا لكن رغم
ذلك نسمع هذه الاصوات التي تدين هذا الجيش
الاسرائيلي المحتل وباق بح العبارات ليس
اقلها ارهابي وقاتل للاطفال الا يضرب ذلك
في الصميم العقيده التي يقوم عليها الجيش
الذي يسمي نفسه الاكثر اخلاقيه في
العالم سيدتي الكريمه كل المقدمه تبع تبع
حضرتك لا اساس لها من الصحه نحن مجتمع
يدافع عن نفسه ولنا حق الدفاع عن النفس
وقد علمونا
الفلسطينيين المقوله الف ام تبكي ولا امي
من حقنا ان ندافع عن نفسنا ونحن مجتمع فيه
كل الشفافيه كل شيء ينشر في جرائد ولنا
لجان في الجيش تعفي جنود الذين لديهم حجج
نفسيه عقد عقده نفسيه او غيرها ولكن لا
نوافق على ان مجموعه قليله ذقي زوبعه في
فنجان تتخذ قرارات على خلفيه سياسيه نحن
لنا حكومه انتخبت ديمقراطيا وهي المسؤوله
على تصرفات الجيش ولذلك كل من تسولت له
نفسه ان يقوم بخطوه منعزله عن السياسه
الرسميه والتي تتخذ قرارات باسم الشعب
بكامله هي غير مقبوله لدينا ونرى هنالك
الكثير
منير
المو
بالمراز على ذلك جمله واحده سيدتي الكريمه
جمله واحده الا وهي انه مدى تطول اسرائيلي
الى الوحدات القتاليه عماله بزيد من يوم
الى يوم هناك اعات وكانه هجره من اسرائيل
لبرا هناك تقطيف من التطوع الى سمعنا وجهه
نظرك لكن ناقشني فيما تبعناه في الفيلم
هؤلاء كلهم مجانين ومرضى عقليين تحت ما
يسمى ببروفايل 21 كما يصمون بانهم مرضى
نفسيون يعني تتحدث عن دفاع اسرائيل هؤلاء
يقولون بان جيشنا لا يهمه وقادتنا لا
يهمهم سوى احتلال الفلسطينيين وقتل
الاطفال والابرياء والعزل هل هذا هو دفاع
اسرائيل هذا هو الجيش الذي لا يقهر وهل
هذا هو العتاد الذي تملكه اسرائيل في
مجابهه هؤلاء الاطفال سيدي هذا هو الجيش
الذي لا يقهر
نعم هذا نعم هذا هو الجيش الذي لا يقهر
وله اوصافه الاخلاقيه ونحن نفتخر فيها
مقارنه مع الشعوب العربيه التي يعني
تطوقنا من كل جانب وتقول على الملاه انهم
يردون شطبنا عن الخريطه واستعمل نم ذج
السيد الدكتور البروفيسور اينشتاين عندما
سئل من قبل احد اليابانيين كيف شرك
بالتطوير القنبله النوويه جاوبه نحن لا
نريد انا رافد على سبيل المثل انا كدكتور
روبن انا رافد ولكن الجانب الثاني الاخر
يريد تسفيه الشعب الاسرائيلي يريد اباده
دوله اسرائيل هذا موجود في ميثاق حماس هذا
هو اعلان العيلات من ايران وهذا ما يقول ح
وهذا ما يخطط ل بعض الخرقات الارهابيه
الفلسطينيه ماذا تتو مردود عليها
اسرائيليا ل المقدمه نحن وضعناها ولا غير
ذلك هذا الكلام اخذناه مما
يقوله فقط على شغله دعنا يعني نتجاذب
اطراف الحديث اتحول فقط على شغله واحده
دعني اتحول السيد ين ساعود ساعود اليك سيد
جدعون سيد جدعون يعني
من الواضح ان هناك حاله انكار واضحه ومن
الواضح ايضا بان هناك تكتم كبير على هذه
الظاهره ورغبه في التقليل من اهميتها هناك
ايضا سمعنا شهادات في الفيلم محاوله لعزل
هؤلاء عن المجتمع بالترغيب او حتى
بالترهيب ابعادهم ادخالهم للسجون ابعادهم
عن عن عملهم الكثير من الممارسات باعتقادك
الى اي مدى بالفعل هؤلاء بات لديهم قناه
بان الخدمه العسكريه في جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي باتت مصدر خجل يخجلون من
الموضوع كون هذا الجيش النظامي لا لا يعني
يقوم بحروب خارجيه تهدد فعلا الكيان
الاسرائيلي بل هو جيش تحول لقتل الاطفال
والابرياء والمدنيين والكلام جاء لشهادات
تابعناها جميعا في
الفيلم
الجيش الذي يطلق على نفسه جيش الدفاع في
ال 50 سنه الماضيه راينا ان الامر يتعلق
بجيش احتلال معظم
الانشطه يتركز على التشبت بالاحتلال
بطرق بشعه ليس هناك دوله اخرى في العالم
تقوم بنفس الممارسات هذا شيء غير مشروع
هذا شيء واضح
[موسيقى]
وثابت الناس يرفضون الانضمام الى هذا
الجيش وهذا اقل ما يمكن ان يفعله مواطن
لاذو اخلاق مواطن له رؤيه ما الذي يمكن
هذا المواطن ان يقوم به عدا هذا الشيء عدا
ان يرفض
الجرائم التي تقترف بشكل يومي الاعتقالات
التعسفيه
والقتل القتل العشوائي
وايضا قتل الاطفال والنساء والشيوخ ايضا
اعتقد ان هؤلاء الذين
يريدون المشاركه في هكذا جرائم لا يسالون
انفسهم سؤالا صريحا وواضحا يجب ان يسالوا
انفسهم ما الذي يفعلونه في هذا الجيش لا
يجب ان يسائل اولئك الذين يرفضون الانضمام
الى هذا الجيش اولئك الذين يريدون ان
ينقوا بانفسهم بعيدا هذه الجرائم ضد
الانسانيه وهذه الجرائم البشعه التي لا
نراها في مناطق اخرى في العالم هذا طبعا
يجعلني اشعر بالخيبه واشعر طبعا بالخجل ان
انتمي الى هذا البلد سيد روبين ترد على
السيد جدعون هو اسرائيلي مثلك ويتحدث عن
خيبه ويتحدث طب بشرط انك تسمحي لي ان اكمل
كلامي التبيعه لهذه اللقاءات انكم
تكع امكانيه الجواب الصريح هناك حركه في
اسرائيل حركه يساريه لا تقبل قرار المنتخب
الاسرائيلي ولوم اوهام يريدون فردها على
الواقعيه المؤلمه والواقعيه المعلمه ان
هناك حماس يكسف بالصواريخ المجتمع
الاسرائيلي الاعزل ونحن لنا الحق بالرد
عليهم بالمثل بل الس ساعين وهناك كمن يقول
احتلال ي يتفضل الطرف الفلسطيني ويتفاوض
معنا نحن نريد ان
نس بجوار دوله ما انا انا توقعت انك لا
تعطيني مجال لاكمل كلامي وانا صابر ولكن
بغض النظر هناك حركه يساريه اسرائيليه لا
تقبل بذلك واذا فعلا سمحنا
بالظواهر التي يعني تريد ان يتم هناك تمرد
في الصفوف الجيش ولحسن حزنا هذه زوبعه في
فنجان هناك من يوهم نفسه انه الجيش
الاسرائيلي اماله تفكك نتيجه بعد ال
الضعاف النفوس الذي نراهم الذين نراهم في
برنامجكم الكريم ليس هناك حركه من هذا
النوع حتى السيد جيدون ليفي هو ظاهره
منزوعه ظاهره لا غير مقبوله في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ولكن نحن شعب ديمقراطي لكل
انسان مثل جيدون ليفي وحتى هؤلاء الذين
يرفضون الخدمه نحن ننشر الظاهره في
الجرائد الاسرائيليه لا نحج من وتون
ويغيرون مجال عمهم اعطيتك الفرصه
م وجزء منهم يعتقل في في السجن دعني اتحول
السيد جدعون اذا تسمع ما قاله السيد روبين
هؤلاء مجموعه من ضعاف النفوس هذا التمرد
يعني ما مستقبله في ظل هذا التعتيم التكتم
والانكار وحتى التضييق على هؤلاء هل هو
ككره ثلج مرشحه ل الارتفاع ام ان باعتقادك
باعتقادك عفوا بان هؤلاء الرافضين للخدمه
المتمردين
والرافضين غير المصاعين للاوامر العسكريه
هل باعتقادك انه يمكن ان يحدث تغييرا ما
هل سيكون لهم
وزنا للاسف يجب ان اكون متحفظا لان القوه
التي يواجهونها قوه كبيره وهذه الحمله
الممنهجه لنزع الشرعيه عنهم وضعهم في سجون
في سجون والتعتيم الاعلامي الواس عن نطاقه
وايضا دور المؤسسه الاعلاميه التي لا
تتحدث
عن الاستعمار هناك رفض للاعتراف بالحقيقه
كنت اليوم في الضفه الغربيه وما اراه بشكل
يومي غير مقبول وهو
مرفوض الكثير ربما لا يعرف ذلك او لا يريد
ان يعرفه اولا يريد ان يعترف بان هناك
حقيقه على الارض احتلال واستعمار اذا كان
المجتمع كله او معظمه يشارك في هذا الجهد
ل رفض الانضمام للجيش اذا حوضهم ل التاثير
وحدودهم
لنمو بشكل اكبر
وربح
عقول الناس في المجتمع اعتقد حضهم قليله
كما تفضلت وسميت
كره الثلج اتمنى ان تكون او تتحول الى كره
ثلج حتى تحرك مشاعر المجتمع الداخلي لدينا
هناك للاسف تراجع في الاخلاق هناك تراجع
في الاخلاق وهذا طبعا يجب ان نتغير سيد
جدعون حاله انكار داخليه لكن ماذا على
الخارج هل التفت الى هذا الموضوع هل اعره
اي اهتمام سواء من ناحيه البحث او التفات
اليه باعتقادك ما الذي يمكن ان يقدمه
الخارج ايضا ليسمع صوت هؤلاء ان كان
مكتوما عليه في
اسرائيل مثلا ما تقومون به اليوم الجزيره
وهذا البرنامج الرائع الذي يطلع العالم
العربي والعالم باسر حول ما يحدث في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه الم
تت يجب ان نقول للمجتمع الدولي بان بلدنا
لا يتحدث بنفس الصوت بنيامين نتنياهو لا
يمثل بلدنا ليس كل المواطنون في مجتمعنا
هم مستوطنون وهم مستعمرون و محتلون
و لا يمكننا ان نقول بان كل شاب من بلدنا
بامكانه او يريد ان يطلق الرصاص على
الاطفال
على النساء والشيوخ اذا مازال هناك بعض
الناس وعون للاسف عددهم قليل وهم منزعجون
وقلقون ولكنهم موجودون وعلى العالم ان
يعرف هذا ويجب ان يدعمهم بقوه سيد ربين
احد الشهود في الفيلم قال بان العالم
سيتذكر قادتنا كقاتل اطفال التاريخ بالفعل
سيحكم في يوم من الايام
وستنبت اطلاقا اثبت التاريخ ذلك يمكن ان
يفلت بجريمته الا تخشون ممن تعتبرونه ضعاف
نفس اليوم ان يكونوا شهودا امام هذه
المحاكم التي قد تنصب يوما للاسرائيليين
لادانتهم على هذه الجرائم ا تسالينني انا
نعم سيد
روبين تساليني انا نعم سيدتي الكريمه اذا
حكينا عن كوارث وجرائم حار فعلينا بس ان
نتطلع فقط الى خروج ما الى حدود مخارج
دوله اسرائيل اسرائيل جنه فوق الارض بحد
ذاتها وبالمقارنة
الاسلامي اللي حوالينا ما هو معنى الارهاب
التي تحاف تكافح ضده اسرائيل ويتضامن معنا
اما بخصوص الاوصاف من قمه من قله قليله من
المنبوذين من امثال جيدون ليفي والجماعه
الخياليه اللي ذكرتيها فهم لا يعتبرون ولا
يمث يمثلون احد باسرائيل
لحس
ديمقراطيه المصيره الديمقراطيه هي نصبت
نتنياهو وهي اللي نصبت الطريق التي تمشي
فيها
دوله امارات او امير هنا او امير هنالك
نحن دوله لنا نظام ديمقراطي ولا
اماره نظام
وحداني لنا قانون
بموجبه يحكم اي مجرم من مك كان ولنا هناك
لجان في الجيش لمن يريد ان يعفى من الخدمه
لاسباب شخصيه فهو حر اما من اراد ان يشطه
القرار الديمقراطي ويفصل بين المواطنين
والجيش ويخلق شرخ في صفوف الجيش واضح ماذا
تفعلون بهؤلاء يدعون السجون سيد روبين بقي
معي للاسف الشديد يعني قرابه الدقيقه
ساتحول بها للسيد السيد جدعون مكتوم سيدتي
فيش شي مكتوم هذا غير صحيح نحن لا نكتم
الجرائد عننا منتهى الشفافيه و دليل على
ذلك يعني لس من نقول سيد جدعون يقول بان
هذه الظاهره تاخذ في وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه وضحت وجهه نظرك ولم اقاطعك
دعني اتحول فقط حتى نقسم الوقت بشكل عادل
للسيد جدعون يعني باعتقادك الى اي مدى
يمكن ان تشكل هذه الشهادات التي تابعناها
الليله في هذا الفيلم من قبل هؤلاء
الاشخاص اي اساس لاي محاكمات مستقبليه
تدين جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بهذه
الجرائم التي ارتكبها في غزه في غزه بحق
اطفال ومدنيين عزل رغم ان السيد روبن يصف
هؤلاء بمجموعه من المنبوذين كما
قال
في التاريخ عندما نعود الى الوراء مجموعات
صغيره كانت على حق وكانت مجموعات كبيره
وكانت
غالبيه على خطا وكانت مجموعات الصغيره
تقلب مجرا التاريخ وكانت تؤثر بشكل كبير
ان الاصوات الشجاعه والاصوات الخلوقه
ستكسب بنهايه المطاف وهذا ما يحدث عندنا
في بلدنا في يوم من الايام ستنتصر هذه
المجموعه الصغيره ويسمع صوتها ورجح الكفه
لص لصالحها بالتاكيد
بنهايه المطاف لا يصح الا الصحيح واذا
كانت غالبيه تدعم القتل والاجرام فهذا
يبقى بنهايه المطاف غير مقبول وغير صحيح
كما قلت سلفا هناك غسل الادمغه ل
غالبيه المجتمع وهذا لا يعني بان غالبيه
المجتمع على على صواب لذلك يجب ان نبقى في
هذا الاتجاه وبالتاكيد هذه المجموعات
الصغيره سيكون لها صوت في المستقبل يسمع
وسيحسم لها الف حساب وهذا التعتيم وهذا
الرفض غير مقبول ولا اعرف اي مجتمع اخر في
العالم يعيش في هذا التعتيم ونعلم ان 15
دقيقه
بعد هذا او على بعد من هذا المكان هناك
تقتيل وهناك احتلال وهناك ترهيب
للناس يجب ان نسمي الامور بمسمياتها
هناك ابعاد الناس عن الواقع وعن الحقيقه
وهذا ما حاولنا بالفعل في حلقه هذه الليله
في نهايه حلقتنا هذه نشكر ضيفين من تل
ابيب الكاتب والصحفي جدعون ليفي والعقيد
المتقاعد المختص في الشان الفلسطيني
والشرق الاوسطي الدكتور روبن لا يفوتنا
مشاهدينا في نهايه حلقه هذه الليله ان
ننوه بالجهد المشكور للزميل الياس كرام
وفريق العمل في مكتبنا برام الله ختام
حلقتنا هذه نلتقيكم باذن الله في حلقه
جديده وبقيه لقصه جديده الاثنين المقبل
بحول الله السلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم
ه